Um, so thanks for everybody who tuned in
for the uh the guest lecture um last
time and thanks to everybody in the
class who asked good questions. Um, I
apologize for the technical
difficulties. We have one more guest
speaker and she and I are going to do an
AV check on the day before to make sure
that we're all set up so that hopefully
that won't steal 10 minutes away from
her talk uh like it did last time. Um,
but Chris's talk was really great. uh he
raised some interesting points that I
would like to highlight again but I'm
not sure if I'm going to have time to do
that today. So I'll save it till the end
and if there's time I'll do that at the
end of today. Uh today we're going to
talk about something else. So um I want
to return to a topic that we discussed a
while ago and uh and cover it in a lot
more depth. So we have spent a lot of
time talking about uh keeping replicas
consistent with each other and um quite
often the situation is that you have
some number of replicas um let's just
say two replicas to keep it simple and
you have updates coming in
and some sort of messages arriving that
cause a change in state on these
replicas. Uh and so both your replicas
can receive these updates that cause
state changes.
Just like with the key value store that
you implemented uh those of you who are
working on the assignment for the class,
uh any replica can receive and deliver
updates. Uh at least that's what you
were supposed to implement. All right.
So in a scenario like this, there's no
leader, right? We're not doing primary
backup or anything like that. Neither
replica is special.
In a scenario like this, if we want
strong consistency, what can we do?
What do you think?
Any
ideas? How would we get strong
consistency in a situation like this
where there's no leader?
It's something that we've talked about.
I saw some joke on Twitter recently that
was like, "If there's ever a really long
pause uh when you're teaching and it
feels awkward, just remember that there
was a 2 hour and 10 minute pause during
uh negotiations during the Korean War."
So,
yours isn't awkward.
All right. So, two or three people have
started typing something and stopped.
So, uh so so let me suggest something
that we could do.
we could use a consensus protocol to
decide where to slot in every event as
it arrives. Um, so say replica 1 uh
receives uh let's say let's say replica
1 receives update A and replica 2
receives update B.
Then replica 1 might say I propose that
we put event A in slot one and replica 2
might say I propose that we put event B
in slot one. Well, one of those will
win, right? Either that or the consensus
protocol won't terminate. Uh, but we
know that it won't end with R1 and R2
having different things in slot one.
That's the agreement part of those three
properties that we say consensus gives
you. Agreement, validity, and
termination, right? So, and if the
consensus protocol doesn't terminate,
uh, you can start over and try again.
Uh, hopefully eventually it will. So,
that's decided on. Then, let's say event
B gets into slot one.
So, we have this little list of slots
and events here
for each process.
What goes into slot two? Well, R1 still
has this event A to take care of. So,
maybe it'll then say, well, I propose
that we put event A in slot two. Maybe
that time there aren't any competing
proposals, so everybody accepts and now
it's been decided. So the order is B
then A.
So
this is a way to ensure that the events
get applied in the same order on each on
each uh replica. Now they they might
arrive in whatever order you're going to
receive them in whatever order you
receive them, but you can wait to
deliver them until you achieve consensus
on what order to deliver them. And so
every process is keeping track of this
list of slots and then they order the uh
they they deliver the events in the
order that's uh that's agreed upon.
But there's a problem. How many messages
had to get sent to reach this point
where both replicas knew that the order
was B then A?
Well,
a whole lot, right? If we have to run a
consensus protocol. So let's say that
there are three acres. So we have our
two replicas
R1 and R2 and those are like the
proposers right
and then say there's three acptors.
So R1 has event gets event A here or
gets update A. It's going to send out
its prepare message, right?
But we said that R2 won, right? So R2
got event B
and R2 sent out its message.
Maybe it's its message landed earlier
here. So it's it's
maybe its message is prepare six.
It gets
responses, promises. In response, this
one here is going to get ignored because
maybe this was a prepare five.
This one is going to get a promise, but
it doesn't matter because it's only one.
So then R2 is going to get to send out
its accept messages for B. So it'll say
something like accept
proposal number six slot one because
we're deciding what goes in slot one and
B. It's saying I propose that B goes in
slot one
and let's say that those accept.
And all that was just to decide on what
goes in slot one, right?
And then later maybe R1 is going to come
along and say, okay,
now I want to do uh event A and it'll
send out its promise messages. It'll get
its responses.
I won't write it all out, but you get
the idea. So a lot of messages have to
get sent. So it looked like how many
messages had to get sent just to get to
the point where we decided what goes in
slot one. Uh well A sent a few that
ultimately ended up not mattering. And
then over here B sent two. Two got sent
in response. B sent two more and then
two got sent in response. So
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. So so eight messages
got sent. And this is in the happy case,
right? Where it only sent to the
smallest majority. So
we still even if it even at that point
looks like 11 messages got sent just to
decide on the first slot. Um and we
still hadn't sent every uh all of the
messages to learners and so forth. So
the point here is consensus protocols
are expensive. The only time that you
really really want to use them is when
it's extremely important that everybody
agrees.
So in this case, we only want to go to
the trouble of agreeing on an order for
A and B if it actually really matters
that they happen in the same order
everywhere
now. I haven't told you anything about
what these events A and B are. Right? So
it's possible that it is really
important that they happen in a
particular order that everybody agrees
on. So quite often in this class, we've
talked about events or messages without
saying anything about the content of
those events or messages. So these these
A and B here are just opaque, right? We
can't uh when we're when we're talking
about consensus, right? The the Paxos
algorithm or any other consensus
algorithm typically, it doesn't look
inside them and see the payload of those
messages.
uh it only sees that they're a message,
right? Um and that's true that's true
for most of the other algorithms we
talked about when we talked about uh the
the causal broadcast algorithm. The
causal broadcast algorithm just sees
messages and their vector clocks. It
doesn't see anything about the content
of those messages. It says uh it says
where they where they go, right? Like
send this to R1. and it sees sees where
the message is supposed to go and it
sees the metadata uh the causal metadata
but we don't know anything about what
those events do right so the algorithm
for for implementing causal uh causal
delivery causal broadcast for example it
doesn't care what those events actually
do it doesn't care if the event is
checking your account balance or
launching rockets or whatever and Paxos
doesn't care either it doesn't care what
events A and B
Um, the Chandandy Lamport algorithm
doesn't care. None of those algorithms
care what the events actually do. In
fact, these algorithms are all so
general and they have to work regardless
of the actual events that are happening,
right? It wouldn't make any sense for
them to sort of look inside the message
and see what the payload is. Uh, because
what what could they even what question
could they even ask about it? Nothing
useful, right?
But as a human being who's looking at
this situation and seeing how much
trouble we're going to to try to figure
out what order should A and B happen in
and as somebody who's developing
applications that have to interact with
this replicated system. Well, you know
what your messages say, right? You know
if you're implementing a key value store
or bank account or whatever.
uh and you know what application
specific properties you want to have be
true, right? You might know that you
don't want a bank balance to go below
zero, for example. So, or let's say that
you're implementing a shopping cart,
right? Uh you might you might want to
enforce that items never get lo dropped
from the cart. Um, so if R1 and R2,
let's say that they are copies of the
shopping cart, coming back to this
picture here, um, and event A is adding
a book to the cart, and event B is
adding, uh, pants to the cart, as we've
talked about before,
then you definitely don't want to pay
the cost of running a consensus protocol
to get everybody to agree, oh, well,
first we're going to add the pants and
then we're going to add the book because
it doesn't matter. They could get added
in either order. So, it would be massive
overkill for this situation to run Paxos
to decide, oh, we're all going to add
the pants to the cart first and then
we're all going to add the book. Now,
the guarantee that you actually want is
going going to depend on your
application's needs, right? There might
be some situations where you really do
do need to ensure that the events happen
in the same order on both and it it'll
depend on the on the message, right?
It'll depend on the event. Um, but I'm
going going to argue that a lot of the
time the safety property that you that
you want is not strong consistency. The
safety property that you actually want
is strong convergence,
which says that replicas that have
delivered the same set of updates have
equivalent state. So we talked about
that before um but I'm going to write it
out here again.
So strong convergence is a weaker
property uh than making sure that all of
the updates get applied on every replica
in exactly the same order. Instead,
you're only saying that if they've
received the same set of updates in some
order, right? Then at that point, their
state is going to be equivalent.
So now if this is what you want to
ensure, this is easier. Now you just
have to make sure that one way or
another everybody delivers the same set
of updates. That might still be hard to
do, but it's probably going to be easier
than making sure that they all deliver
the same updates in the same order.
Okay, so
we know that if replicas represent
shopping carts and that if events are
adding items to carts, then to have
replicas agree,
we just need to make sure that the same
set of events shows up at every replica
in every order. Now note that that if
you make an observation at some
intermediate point like if a client
makes an observation before all of the
items have been added to both carts then
those observations might be inconsistent
right so strong convergence doesn't make
any guarantees about those sort of
intermediate observations but it does
say that if they've gotten the same set
of updates then at that point their
state will be the same. So strong
convergence we know works well for this
shopping cart situation. Um but what's
the general principle here? We know what
to do for shopping carts, but how do we
generalize that? How do we write down
the the general principles?
So, for that, uh, I want to introduce a
little bit of math. Um, but it's a lot
of it is math that you've seen already.
So, reach back in your brain to where we
when we talked about partially ordered
sets.
So, can somebody remind me what the
definition of a partially ordered set
is?
Okay, so a suggestion in chat is a set
where all elements can be related with a
binary comparison. Well, maybe not all,
right? Um, so that's what the where the
partial part comes in.
So it's going to be a set. That's right.
So it's a set
uh call it s
together with a binary relation.
And that might be written like this
or maybe it'll be written like this.
maybe in some other way. Um that's going
to relate some of the elements of S to
each other. So the partial part of
partially ordered set says that not
every pair of elements in this set S is
necessarily related by the relation. So
in other words, not every pair of
elements is comparable.
Uh and so for a partial order, um let's
stick with this uh this notation.
Uh there there are three axioms that
hold for this relation. Uh so what are
they?
Right? So reflexivity is the first one.
Reflexivity says that
for all elements of S,
all elements A of S, A is related to
itself by the relation. That's
reflexivity. Uh, next one is
anti-ymmetry.
What does anti-ymmetry say? Somebody
want to remind me.
Yeah. So for all
A and B in S,
if A is related to B
and B is related to A,
then A and B have to be the same.
And then the last one is transitivity.
What does transitivity say?
Right? So if you had
A, B, and C,
then
if A is related
to B and B is related to C,
then A is related to C. So this relation
is transitive.
So what's an example of a partially
ordered set? uh what would be this set S
and what's the relation on the elements
of S? What's a classic example? Anybody
want to name one
or even a non-classic example
H. Somebody suggest numbers. H. So,
okay. Uh, you could have a set of
numbers. Okay. What relation relating
them?
human heights.
Okay, again you could have a set of
heights, but what would be the relation?
Okay, so these examples are they're so
yes they are examples of partial orders
in the sense that you could have a set
of numbers right and then you could
relate them and this would in fact be
true right or heights no sure um but
these aren't especially exciting uh
examples of partial orders because I
would argue that those are actually
total orders right the num like if you
take like the integers for example
there's a total border on them, right?
Uh, and there's a total order on on on
people's heights as well. So, these are
these are examples. So,
total orders are a special case of
partial orders, but the really
interesting partial orders are the ones
where you have elements that are not
comparable.
So, there's a reason why I brought up
shopping carts before, uh, because I was
I was trying to nudge you toward a
particular example of of of partial
orders. So the usual go-to example for
explaining partial orders is to have S
be the set of all subsets of some other
set. So for the so the relation here
would be would be set inclusion. So the
elements of S would be let's say
subsets
of
the set containing the book,
the pants,
and another thing that I might want to
buy, a blender.
So
S would be
this set. It would be the empty set and
then the set containing the book,
the set containing the pants,
the set containing the blender,
the set containing the book and the
pants.
The book in the blender.
The pants in the blender.
And all three.
I hope you like my drawing skills. So
that would be S. And then what would be
the relation? It's said inclusion. So
for instance,
the set containing the pants
is a subset or equal to
the set containing
the pants in the book.
But what's an example of um of two
members of S here that are not
comparable?
Right. Yeah. So, if you had the pants
and then you had another set of the book
and the blender,
um then this is not true.
And this is not true either.
So this is a partial order rather than a
total order because there are some pairs
of elements of S that are not related by
the ordering relation or same goes for
any of the the singleton sets, right? Uh
like the set containing just the book is
not smaller than the set containing just
the pants and the set containing just
the pants is not smaller than the set
containing just the book. Okay, so this
is all stuff that we've talked about a
little bit so far. Um so it's all
review. so far. Um but but now we can
talk about something new.
So I'm going to introduce a new concept
here um which is the concept of upper
bounds.
So we can pick out any two elements of S
here. Remember that in this case the
elements of S are themselves sets. So
this is an element for example or this
is an element.
Um, and we can ask, okay, which elements
of S or that that was kind of a boring
example to pick out those two. Um, but
we'll say this, which elements of S are
at least as big as both of those
according to the ordering relation. So,
let's pick some some that are more
interesting. So, let's say let's say
that I pick um the pants
and the blender. So the question is
which elements of S are at least as big
as both of those
So which elements of S here are at least
as big as both this element and this
element?
Yeah. So it's going to have to be
any element that had that contains both
of them, right? So certainly this would
be at least as big as both of them,
right? Because it's the set containing
both. But also this one here that
contains all three is at least as big as
both.
So these two elements
here
are
upper bounds
of
the set containing the pants
and the set containing the blender.
Or if we picked out, let's say, the
empty set
and the set containing the book and the
pants. Well, which are going to be at
least as big as as both? Well, it's
going to be this one. this one itself is
at least as big as itself, right? And
also the one with all of them is at
least as big.
So that's called an upper bound. Um so
here's the definition.
We'll say given a partially ordered set.
By the way, sometimes people abbreviate
this as post set.
So here's our partially ordered set, our
S and our relation.
We'll say an upper bound
of two elements in S
is
an element
in S
such that
A is less than or equal to that element
and B is less than or equal to that
element. So again an example would be uh
like if s was our uh set of all all
subsets of of pants blender and book
then the upper bound
unupound
Upper bounds of the set containing pants
and the set containing blender will be
this
and this.
So notice that there can be more than
one right we don't say the upper bound
we say an upper bound. So
these particular two elements have two
upper bounds.
Okay. So there could be many upper
bounds. Which upper bounds are going to
be the most interesting do you think?
or the most useful.
H the uppest upper bound is a
suggestion. Okay. So yeah, maybe so this
one here might be interesting, but I
would argue that this one here actually
isn't super interesting because like
let's say I want
the upper bounds of some other elements
um of our S. So let's say that I want
the upper bounds of empty set and
book
and pants.
So what are going to be the upper bounds
there? Well, the upper bounds are going
to be book and pants
because it's at least as big as itself
and it's definitely at least as big as
the empty set. And then also
book pants blender, right?
Because that's at least as big as both
also.
So notice that book pants blender is in
both of these, right? Or pants book
blender. It doesn't matter what order.
Um, so that upper bound is maybe not so
exciting because it's going to occur,
right? No matter what uh what what we're
asking for. It it doesn't really it
doesn't give us as much information,
right? So the upper bounds that are
really going to be the most interesting
in most situations are going to be the
smallest ones.
How do we formally define what it means
for an upper bound to be the smallest?
Well,
order theorists have thought of that,
too.
So we'll say this
an upper bound
of two elements in a set
is
the least
upper bound.
love for short or join
that's another word for it.
If
let's call this upper bound u I guess an
upper bound u
if u
is less than v
for each
upper bound v
of a and b.
We're assuming that these uh that u and
v are also elements of this set at s
here.
So there could be many upper bounds like
we saw here.
Um but the least upper bound is going to
be the one where there aren't any upper
bounds that are bigger. That's what this
says here. It says an upperbound u is
the least upper bound if it's smaller
than any other upper bounds that there
are.
So the least upper bound of pants and
blender is of the set containing pants
and the set containing blender is the
set containing pants and blender. The
least upper bound of the empty set and
the set containing book and pants is the
set containing book and pants.
So those are least upper bounds
in this partially ordered set that we
have been talking about
of sub uh all the subsets of book pants
and blender.
Is it true that every two elements are
going to have a least upper bound?
What do you think? Consider any pair of
elements in S.
Are those elements going to have a least
upper bound? Yeah, they do.
So a partially ordered set that has this
property where every two elements have a
least upper bound has a fancy name. It's
called a join semi lattice.
So somebody just said in in chat uh the
the full set of them is the is the least
upper bound for all. So, um, well, no,
right? Because, so they're they're
they're they're all going to have, uh,
this as one of their upper bounds,
right? But, but most of them are going
to have something else as their least
upper bound.
But it is true that everything is
guaranteed to have a least upper bound.
Okay. Worst case least upper bound.
Well, that's that's uh I guess yeah,
okay, that's one way to think of it.
Yeah, you can think if there's no other
upper bound, if there's no better upper
bound to be had, you know that in the
worst case, at least they're going to
have this as their as as their least
upper bound. Sure.
Okay. I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily
use the phrase guaranteed least upper
bound, right? Because um uh
I I think that confuses matters, right?
because um
because most pairs of elements in S are
going to have a better uh least upper
bound, a lower least upper bound if you
will. Okay, so here's the definition
again of join semilattice.
Okay, so if order theorists came up with
this special terminology for partially
ordered sets in which every two elements
have have a least upper bound. Um, okay.
Well, if they bothered to come up with
that term, then it must be true that
there are partially ordered sets where
not every two elements have a least
upper bound.
But can you think of one that that that
doesn't? Can you think of a partially
set where it's where it's not true that
every two elements have a least upper
bound? It's actually kind of hard to
think of one.
H.
So, people are giving some suggestions
in chat. Um, I'm not sure I completely
understand all the suggestions. Um, but,
um, but let me give you an example of
one that's that's pretty simple.
So
think about a
boolean register.
By this I just mean a variable that can
be empty or it can be true or it can be
false. So
there's a state that it can be in that's
empty
or it can be in the state of true
or it can be in the state of false.
So the set of possibilities
is empty, true, false. Right? And we can
put an ordering on these, right? So I've
put empty at the bottom, right? So
we're saying empty is less than true.
Empty is less than false.
Um,
true is less than itself. False is less
than itself.
Empty
or less than or equal, excuse me. True
is less than or equal to true. False is
less than or equal to false. Empty is
less than or equal to empty.
There it is. There's the there's the
complete relation written down.
Is it a partially ordered set? Let's
make sure. So what do we have to do to
make sure something is a partially
ordered set? Well, we have to check if
it's if the if the relation is
reflexive, anti-ymmetric, and
transitive, right? Well, we can see that
it's reflexive right here.
So
remember, it's reflexive if everything
is is uh uh related to itself by the
relation. So we see that that's true.
True is less than or equal to true.
False is less than or equal to false.
Empty is less than or equal to empty. So
refle reflexive checks out. Um is it
anti-ymmetric?
Uh recall what anti-ymmetry says. Um so
anti-ymmetry says that uh if a is
related to b and b is related to a then
a is equal to b. Um well we don't have
any cases where um A is related to B and
B is related to A except for these ones
that we've already done that are um uh
uh where they are equal. So it is
anti-ymmetric that checks out.
transitive.
Well, for transitive it would have to be
like
if A is related to B and B is related to
C, then A is related to C. But there
aren't any cases where you have a a
stack of related things like this,
right? Because our our lattice here is
only so high. Um, so it's vacuously
transitive as well. So it checks out.
It's a partially ordered set because
this relation meets all the
qualifications of being reflexive and
anti-ymmetric and transitive. But it's
not a joint semiattice. And you can see
looking at it that it's not because we
have true and false here. But they don't
have a least upper bound. Right? If you
took if you picked out these two
elements and you said what's their
what's their least upper bound? Well,
they don't have one. So
this is an example of a post set
that is not
a join semiattice.
So to bring this back to distributed
systems,
if we have
our two replicas, right?
And
one of them has received a message that
says set the register to true.
And the other one has received a a
message that says set the register to
false.
Well, now we're in trouble, right?
Because we don't have a way to combine
true and false. It's not like the
example with the shopping cart items,
right? Where where we had the book and
the pants and we could just combine
them. Well, we don't have any way to
combine true and false uh because they
don't have an upper bound. Uh they don't
have any upper bound at all and they
definitely don't have a least upper
bound.
So if you can imagine that these are
requests coming in from some sort of
clients, right? Um well, replica replica
2 could you know set the register to
false and then it could go ahead and
forward this message over here, right?
And then register one who had already
set the register to true could reset it
to false.
Okay? And then this could go over here
and it could be reset to true.
So they don't have an upper bound. Well,
how would you solve this? Well, you
could go back to the thing that I
discussed at the beginning of class,
right? Where where these messages come
in and then we have to run a consensus
protocol to decide who does what, right?
Uh or to decide which one gets applied
first. So instead of applying or
delivering this message right away,
instead you could say, well, I propose
that the first thing is true or I
propose that the first thing is false
and then I propose that the next thing
is is so on. So you could do that to
solve this problem, but as we talked
about, consensus is really expensive. So
you want to avoid doing it uh if it's
not necessary. So you don't want to do
it specifically, you don't want to do it
in situations uh when what you have is
something like the shopping cart. In
other words, if
the state updates that you're making can
be thought of as elements of a partially
ordered set that is a joint semi
lattice,
then you should not have to do something
like consensus in order to resolve these
conflicts. Instead, you can resolve the
problem by taking the least upper bound.
So, I'm going to make an informal claim.
If the states
that replicas can take on
can be thought of
as elements
of
a join semiattice
and remember that that means that every
two elements have a least upper bound.
Then
there is a natural way
of resolving conflicts
between replicas
without
consensus.
That's my claim. I call it an informal
claim because there are words in here
like natural, right? Which I'm I'm not
defining what it means to be natural,
right? But
there's a lot of interesting work
that uses something like this property,
this property that I'm I'm I'm this
claim that I'm making here.
uh to do conflict resolution. And you
can think about it yourself and decide
whether whether you think it makes
sense. If you're interested in these
kinds of ideas, uh I recommend looking
up something called conflict free
replicated data types
or CRDTs.
which are an embodiment of this idea.
So this is to me this this this is this
is one of the ideas that got me into
thinking about distributed systems. I
was thinking about this kind of stuff in
the context of uh of shared memory
parallel programming
and then I learned that people were
applying the same kind of reasoning to
distributed systems and that's how I got
into distributed systems because I
thought this was so cool.
So if you find this inspiring too, I
hope you'll go and and learn about CRDTS
and check it out.
Okay. So, finally, um here's another
thing to think about. Actually, before I
before I talk about the last thing, um
let's do a quiz.
All
right, we'll wait one more minute.
Okay.
So, here's one last thing to think about
on this topic. So we've been talking
about
conflicts between replicas
that can arise uh when different clients
are adding different items to a set.
Right? So let's go back to just thinking
about the sets, right?
So
this client is adding the book,
this client is adding the pants.
Um, so we're we're saying that this
isn't a situation that calls for
consensus, right? Because we could both
as long as we're treating these updates
as uh adding elements to a set, then it
doesn't really matter what order the
elements get added to the set. Uh, as
long as we end up with the same set in
both cases.
Um and this is uh and this is especially
true um this is especially useful this
property that these um these sets end up
being the same uh this is this is
especially useful um under network
partitions right because uh if
communication were instantaneous between
these two replicas then we wouldn't have
to worry about any of this stuff right
but it's not and it's especially not if
you have a network partition between
them so if these replicas can't
communicate for quite a while then it
could take a while before you get to to
a situation where everybody has both
updates. Uh but at least we know if if
this property of strong convergence
holds then we then we know that once
everybody has gotten the same set of
updates then their state will agree.
Um but this is but but so far we've only
been talking about adding items to the
set. But if clients are also allowed to
remove items then things get more
complicated, right? So, if this client
adds the book to the shopping cart
and then they later decide that they
want to remove the book,
now things get complicated. Let's say
that this network partition was present
for a while and then it healed, right?
So maybe this uh this update of the book
was able to get over here and then the
network partition happened again and so
this uh replica over here never finds
out about the book being removed. So
maybe this replica over here did find
out about the pants. So at this point
this replica thinks that only the pants
are in the set because it thinks that
the book has been removed. This one over
here thinks that the the book is still
there. And so this is exactly how you
get into that situation that that was
described in the Dynamo paper where
deleted items could reappear in shopping
carts.
So to be a little bit more formal about
it, why did that happen? Well, the
contents of a card are represented as a
set and the conflict resolution
operation which in Dynamo took place on
the client, but you could also imagine
it taking place on the replicas. That's
what happens with CRDTS. um the the
conflict resolution operation uh takes
the least upper bound of of multiple
versions of a cart. With Dynamo, that
happened to be the set union. Um so when
that happens, if an item has been
deleted from one replica, but the delete
hasn't yet propagated to the other
replicas,
then the item could reappear when the
older replica
gets unioned together with the newer
one. So on in Dynamo in particular, if
the client asks for the contents of the
card at this point, they might get both
copies and then the client would have to
union those together.
So how do you deal with this removal
problem, right?
you could go to all the trouble of
making sure that the updates that that
so that that informal claim that I was
making before uh was that you you want
to be able to consider your updates
operation update operations or you want
to be able to consider your states
rather as elements of a joint semi
lattice. You could go to all the trouble
of making sure that the states that
replicas take on are elements of a joint
semi lattice but then everything gets
thrown out as soon as you have to handle
removal, right?
But wait, it turns out that there are
some tricks for dealing with that as
well. So one of those tricks is to
separately keep track of all of the
elements of a set that have been
deleted.
So let's look a little bit at what that
would look like. So
if you're let's say replica one and
replica 2 um replica one uh keeps track
of both additions
and removals
and same thing for replica 2.
Okay,
so replica one
um
finds out that the book has been added,
right?
And they find out that the pants have
been added
and then they find out that the book has
been removed.
Replica 2
finds out that the pants have been added
in the book
and they never happen to find out about
about any removals. Okay.
Um so when you sync up two replicas,
what you can do is
take the union of these of the addition
sets
and subtract
union
of removal sets.
So then you would end up with
minus
the book
which of course would just give you the
set containing the pants
which is what you wanted because the
book has been removed. So that would be
one trick that you could use to deal
with this question of removals. And
you're still using uh this concept of of
of sets and union. So union is our is
our least upper bound in this case. So
now there's two different least upper
bounds involved, right? There's the
least upper bound of the addition set.
There's the least upper bound of the
removal set. Um so you need to keep
track of these two sets on each replica.
And these these removal sets, these
deletion sets uh are known as
Tombstone sets,
which is kind of a cute name.
So that helps. But this still doesn't
solve all your problems, right?
So for instance, what if you add
something and then you remove it and
then you decide to add it again, right?
So let's say that I've added the book
and then I've removed it and then I
decide no, I actually still want the
book so I add it again. Well, if I try
to add it again to the addition set,
right, it's already there. So um adding
a new element to a set and it's already
there, you know, just adds it doesn't do
anything, right? It's still in the
removal set. So it would still get
removed when I do this subtraction
operation.
So you have to do some serious thinking
about what you want the the behavior of
your replicated object to be right under
this behavior. You can remove something
but you can't add it back again after
it's been removed.
So if anybody has ever removed it, it's
not coming back. And so you have to be
very careful, right? Is that the
behavior that you want?
And if you wanted to solve this, then
once again, you're back to that question
of having to to come up with a specific
order. So, one thing that you might do
is um you know, you can kind of proceed
with these um additions and removals in
arbitrary order, but as soon as somebody
wants to add something that's already
been removed, you can do a check at the
time that you're that that you're adding
something to say, okay, has this thing
ever been removed? Do I know about any
removals? Right? And then at that point,
um, you could do, um, you you you could
do some sort of, uh, global
synchronization at that point to try to
make sure that you're caught up on all
the updates that have occurred so far.
Make sure everybody agrees. Have a sort
of, uh, have a coordination point. Uh,
now that makes things slow, very slow,
right? But it might be the price that
you're willing to pay if you want to
allow for these sorts of multiple
removals. Um there are other choices,
other design choices that you could make
as well. Um you could say that additions
always win over removals, right? Um and
that might be the semantics that you
want as well. It depends. Um so so the
point is uh this is hard. It's hard to
do right and people have put a lot of
thought uh in the last 10 years or so
into how to do this right in distributed
systems and some some very interesting
and sophisticated data structures have
been designed to try to address these
kinds of problems. Most of these uh data
structures have not yet made it into
production systems although some of them
have. Uh but this is an active area of
research and um I I think it has a lot
of potential for solving real problems.
uh if it could be um uh if if it could
be made usable enough. So something that
I'm thinking about in my own research uh
is so recall that you know for this sort
of thing to work and back to my informal
claim here um so if the states that
replicas can take on can be thought of
as elements of a as a join semi lattice.
Well, if you're a developer, you don't
know, right, whether the states that
replicas can take on can be thought of
as elements of a join semilattice or
not. So, you want somebody else to to
think about that for you, maybe. So, and
and as as we've seen, reasoning about
this can be really complicated. So, um
so maybe you want some kind of
verification that this is true. Uh that
these things that you kind of think are
probably joint simules, but are they
really? No. um you want you want some
formal verification that this is in fact
the case. So something that I'm thinking
about in my research is how do you how
do you verify that these data structures
actually have the properties that that
we say that they do. And so that's
something that I'm thinking about and if
you want to talk to me more about that
you can. All right. Um that's it for
today. Uh I didn't get time to talk
about the stuff that um that I wanted to
to kind of touch on some ideas from from
Chris Colland's talk. Um but I'll talk
about that next time. Have a wonderful
weekend. Take care.